สวัสดีค่ะครู
ฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้
วัน
อาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 30 ค่ะอ
ทำไมเราต้องทำเสียงแบบนี้ฮาโลวีนไงเดือน
อะไรคะครูฟ้าเดือนตุลาคมคมๆๆๆไม่ต้องมี
เอคโคปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วัน
เสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
29 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 อืปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันจันทร์ไม่เหลืองเลยอ่ะไม่ชอบนะคะ
เปลี่ยน
ใหม่วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
[เพลง]
31 เดือนอะไร
คะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปี
ค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้
เวลา 233 นอุ้ย 23 น 23 นนักเรียนนะคะ 23
นคนไทย 23 นกี่นาที 56 นี
ค่ะอีก 4 นะ
นีก็จะเป็นเที่ยง
คืน
ฮวน
ฮาโลวีนแล้ววันนี้เราจะมาผีกันเหรอคะไม่
นะคะนักเรียนทำไมครูฟ้าครูหญิงบิ้ว
ฮาโลวีนมากๆบิ้วขนาดนี้แต่ไม่เกี่ยวอะไร
กับฮาโลวีนนะคะแต่ว่าปกติเนี่ยเวลาที่ครู
หญิงเนี่ยถามเวลาครูครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยดู
เวลาที่ไหนคะครูฟ้าก็ต้องดูเวลาที่นาฬิกา
ค่ะุ
หญิงไม่ใช่ค่ะดูที่โทรศัพท์ค่ะอันเนี้ย
อ๋อดูที่นาฬิกาก็ต้องครูฟ้าก็ต้องใส่
นาฬิกาข้อมือหรือว่านาฬิกา
ผนังดูที่โทรศัพท์นะล่ะค่ะนักเรียนใช่ค่ะ
เอแล้วเวลาสมมุติว่าถ้าครูหญิงถามครูฟว่า
ครูฟ้าเวลากี่โมงแล้วเนี่ยครูฟ้าแบบยก
โทรศัพท์ให้ดู
มยหรือว่าครูฟ้าดูแล้วก็บอกครูฟ้าดูแล้ว
ก็บอกครูหญิงแบบว่าอ้อวันนี้กี่โมงนะหรือ
ว่าวันทีฟ้าก็ดูใน iPad นะคะใน iPad ก็จะ
มีนาฬิกาใช่มั้ย้าก็ดูใน iPad ออืใช่เนาะ
ูหญิงก็คิดเหมือนกันนะคะว่าตอนนี้นะตอน
นี้ช่วงปีนี้อนะหมายถึงว่าอตอนนี้ะกันนะ
คะค่ะคนส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยดูเวลาจากโทรศัพท์
เนาะอย่างครูหญิงอ่ะค่ะครูหญิงเป็นคนไม่
ใส่นาฬิกาข้อมืออยู่แล้วนะไม่ใส่นะนาฬิกา
ข้อมืออลผหญิงไม่ชอบเหรอคะใช่
ค่ะอันนี้นาฬิกาข้อมือใช่ๆๆนาฬิกาข้อผู้
หญิงไม่ชอบใส่มันคันไงมันร้อนน่ะออเวลา
ใส่แล้วแบบเออมันคันแล้วแบบเราถอดออกมา
อือ
แล้วเหม็นนะคะอ่าถ้าผู้หญิงไม่ใส่นาฬิกา
ข้อมือเนี่ยแล้วผู้
หญิงมีนาฬิกานี้
มั้ยคือูหญิงต้องเอานาฬิกานาฬิกาแขวน
เนี่ยใส่กระเป๋าออกจากบ้านเหรอ
คะคือเมื่อก่อนไม่มีอันนี้มันเป็นนาฬิกา
ที่บ้าน
นาฬิกานี้เวลาเราดูข้างบนน่ะนาฬิกาแขวน
ใช่ไม่มีหรไม่ก็เมื่อเมื่อก่อนเราก็ดู
เวลาเอาแบบว่าเออถ้าอยู่บน BTS ก็ดูบน BTS
ดูที่ข้อมูลคนอื่นไงเวลาครูหญิงนั่งใช่
มั้ยแล้วอยากว่าเวลากี่โมงก็แบบดูอ๋อโอเค
โอเคแต่ตอนนี้ไม่เป็นไรแล้วค่ะเพราะว่า
เราเนี่ยมีโทรศัพท์อ่าโทรศัพท์เนี่ยนะคะ
เป็นของ
ที่ต้องอยู่กับเราตลอดเวลาอืเป็นของที่
เรารักมากๆใช่มั้ยคะคุขาดได้ใช่ค่ะขาดไม่
ได้แล้วก็ยิ่งโทรศัพท์ในตอนนี้นะคะมีทุก
อย่างมีทุกอย่างก็
คือมี
อาหารมี
นาฬิกามีอาหารก็ Grab  Food อื starbuck
เ้าไม่ได้เป็นสปอนเซอร์นะคะมีแชทหรือว่า
จะต้องใช้เงินก็มีแอปธนาคารอย่างเงี้ย
เห็นมั้ยเนี่ยธนาคารธนาคารอืทำไมโทรศัพท์
มีทุกอย่างหรือว่าวิดีโอนี้ Apple เป็น
สปอนเซอร์หรอคะไม่ค่ะแต่ก็เลยทำให้
โทรศัพท์เนี่ยนะคะโทรศัพท์ของเราเราเรียก
ว่าของส่วนตัวเนาะก็คือของครูหญิงคนเดียว
ถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะหยิบโทรศัพท์ครูหญิงครู
ฟ้าก็ต้องถามก่อน
แต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยก็แบบไม่ให้ไม่ให้ไม่ให้
ครูฟ้าหยิบโทรศัพท์ครูหญิงครูหญิงครูฟ้า
ขอหน่อยไม่ให้
ทำไมไม่ให้ครูหญิงหวงโทรศัพท์ค่ะไม่ให้
ครูฟ้าดูเดี๋ยวไม่ให้ครูฟ้าดูผู้หญิงทำไม
ครูฟ้าขอดูนิดเดียวเองขอดูนิดเดียวขอดู
หน่อยได้
มยไม่ได้โทรศัพท์เนี่ยมันเป็นของเรานะถ้า
เ้าก็ครูฟ้าไม่ได้ขอขอดูถ้าครูฟ้าดูครู
หญิงให้ครูฟ้าดูแล้วแล้วถ้าครูฟ้าไปกดที่
เนี่ที่รูปแล้วอาจครูฟ้าอาจจะเจอรูปรูป
อะไรหรือเปล่าครูหญิงไม่อยากให้ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยดูรูปของครูหญิงไงครูหญิงไม่อยากให้
ครูฟ้าดูรูปของครูหญิงเหรอคะหรือไม่อยาก
ให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเห็นรูปของครูหญิง
อืหญิงก็หวงไงเออไม่แล้วครูฟ้าล่ะคะนี่
เราไม่ต้องแชร์ก็ได้เนาะนัก
เรียนแล้วครูฟ้าล่ะเออครูฟ้าเนี่ยถ้าครู
หญิงบอกว่าครูฟ้าครูฟ้าขอยืมโทรศัพท์
หน่อยโทรศัพท์ครูหญิงไม่มีแบตเตอรี่ครู
หญิงขอยืมโทรหาครูเอ๋หน่อยครูฟ้าให้มยถ้า
ครูหญิงขอยืมโทรศัพท์โทรครูฟ้าโอเคค่ะอ่ะ
ครูฟ้าให้ยืนได้นะเอาไว้โทรเท่านั้นถ้าู
หญิงโทรก็ไม่หวงไงอ่าครูฟ้าไม่กลัวว่าครู
หญิงหยิบมาแล้วก็กดดูเหรออุ๊ยครูฟ้าแชท
กับใครอ่ะอุ๊ยรูปครูฟ้ากับใครครูฟ้าไม่
ไม่กลัวหรอก็ถ้าครูฟ้าให้ครูหญิงยืมครู
ฟ้าก็จะยืนมองอ๋อโอเคครูหญิงก็โอเคฮัลโหล
อ่าโอเคโอเคโอเค
อ๋อแล้วครูครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีอะไรในโทรศัพท์
ที่ครูฟ้าห่วงมยไม่อยากให้คนอื่น
ดูแน่นอนว่าคว่าไม่ต้องนะคะสตปแชร์ดีกว่า
Stop แชร์นะคะอะไร
คะ
อืมแน่นอนว่าแอปพลิเคชั่นแรกนะคะที่ห่วง
ก็คือรูปภาพนะคะ
อ่าครูฟ้ากดให้นักเรียนดูได้มั้ยคะเอ้า
บอกหวงค่ะครูหญิงให้นักเรียนดูได้ด้วยหรอ
หวงก็คือไม่อยากให้ดูไงอืทำไมเราต้องหวง
รูปภาพด้วยอ่ะจริงๆเนาะครูฟ้าก็ไม่ได้มี
อะไรนะคะในรูปภาพเนี่ยใช่พี่มีมเออแต่ก็
ว่าสมมุติว่าครูหญิงก็มีรูปอ่ะถ้าเรามี
รูปตัวเองใช่มยครูหญิงชอบถ่ายรูปตัวเอง
หรือว่าไปเที่ยวที่ไหนแล้วให้ครูฟ้าถ่าย
ให้เนี่ยนาย
อพรที่รสึกว่าเราไม่สวยเราไม่หล่อเราดู
ไม่ดีหรือเปล่าบางคนก็เลยหวงเพราะว่าุ
หญิงคิดว่าแอปพลิเคชั่นหรืออะไรที่อยู่ใน
โทรศัพท์อ่ะที่คนหวงมากที่สุดไม่อยากให้
คนอื่นดูเนี่ยก็คือรูปภาพรูปภาพส่วนใหญ่
คนจะรู้สึกว่าเอ้ยอันนี้มันไม่ได้นะมัน
เป็นของของเรานะมันเป็นความลับห้ามดูนะ
ฉันหวงแต่โทรศัพท์ครูฟ้าไม่มีรูปครูฟ้า
เลยนะคะใช่ค่ะครูหญิงก็เลยงงว่าทำไมครู
ฟ้าหวง
ค่ะมีทุกอย่างเลยเป็นความลับคนอื่นดูไม่
ได้ครูฟ้ารู้สึกว่ามันเป็นอะไรที่เนี่ย
ค่ะลูกเห็นมั้ยแแต่ว่ามันเป็นอะไรที่ดู
เป็นส่วนตัวเนาะมันเป็นของเราใช่มันแบบเอ
ถึงแม้ว่าจะไม่มีรูปครูฟ้านะคะก็อาจจะมี
รูปแมวรูปหมารูปไอดอลที่ครูฟ้าชอบแต่ครู
ฟ้าก็หวงไงเพราะว่าแบบมันก็มีรูปสลิปโอน
เงินของครูฟ้าด้วยนะ
คะอ๋อเดี๋ยวถ้าครูหญิงเห็นครูหญิงก็จะรู้
ว่าอุ๊ยครูฟ้าโอนเงินทำไมโอนเงินซื้อของ
บ่อยจังเลยใช่ผู้หญิงก็จะรู้ว่าครูฟ้าโอน
เงินบ่อยๆอ่าครูหญิงรู้แล้วค่ะครูฟ้าอะไร
คะูหญิงถ้าเป็นสลิปโอนเงินเนี่ยเราก็เรา
ก็อาจจะครูฟ้าอาจจะจะไม่ได้หวงครูหญิงมาก
ๆแต่อาจจะหวงคุณแม่ไม่อยากให้คุณแม่ดูอื
อยากให้แม่เห็นเดี๋ยวแม่รู้ว่าฟ้าโอนเงิน
ซื้ออะไรเนี่ยฟ้าโอนเงินซื้ออะไรเนี่ยอื
เห็นมยก็หวงเลยนะคะไม่อยากให้คุณแม่เห็น
ด้วยแต่ว่าเพื่อนก็คุณฟ้าก็ไม่ชอบให้เข้า
แอปรูปภาพเหมือนกันค่ะรู้สึกว่าจะเข้าไป
ดูอะไรมันไม่มีอะไรหรอกแต่ก็จะเข้าไปดู
อะไรอุ๊ยทำไมโกรธขนาดนี้ล่ะค่ะอโกรธอัน
นั้นก็คือแอปพลิเคชันที่ห่วงนะคะรูปภาพนะ
โฟโตแล้วก็โฟโตนะคะมีอีกมั้ยคะอะไรที่ครู
ฟ้าหวงที่แบบไม่ให้คนอื่น
[เพลง]
ดูหรือ
ว่าเป็นความลับบอกใครไม่ได้
Twitter ค่ะทำไม
อ่ะทำไม Twitter ถึงห่วงอ่ะค่ะก็ Twitter
มันเป็นโซเชียล Media ไม่ใช่หรอใช่ค่ะแต่
ว่าไม่รู้สิบางที Twitter ครูฟ้าก็มีหลาย
ๆแานะคะเพราะไม่ได้มี acc เดียวนะคะใน
Twitter นะคะนัก
เรียนโอเคเข้าใจแล้วค่ะว่าทำไมหวงเพราะ
ว่ามีบางาที่เรารู้สึกว่ามันเป็นส่วนตัว
เราไม่
อยากใช่บางก็เป็นเหมือนไดรี่ของครูฟ้าฟ้า
อาจจะคุยคนเดียวนะคะแต่ว่านั่นแหละมันก็
คือ tter เนี่ยมันเป็นสิ่งที่ค่อนข้างหวง
นะคะแต่ว่าเออใช่ค่ะถ้าเป็น acc ที่มี
เพื่อนๆ Follow อ่ะก็โอเคกให้ดูได้เลยไม่
มีอะไรไม่มีอะไรอยู่แล้วนะคะก็โอเคแต่ว่า
บาง acc เนี่ยมันก็ก็ห่วงเนาะเพราะว่าใช่
เพราะว่าไดอารี่เนี่ยมันก็เหมือนเป็นอะไร
ที่เป็นเรื่องส่วนตัวของเราอ่ะบางอย่าง
สมมุติครูหญิงโกรธครูฟ้าใช่มยครูหญิงก็มา
เขียนลงไดอารี่อย่างเงี้ยแล้วครูหญิงให้
ครูฟ้าดูครูฟ้าก็รู้สิว่าครูหญิงโกรธครู
ฟ้ามันต้องเป็นความลับไงมันเป็นเรื่อง
ส่วนตัวของเราเราก็เลยห่วงนะคะถูกต้องค่ะ
ก็เลยห่วงแอปเอ่อ Twitter นะคะแล้วก็อีก
แอปนึงที่ภูฟ้าพูดไปเมื่อกี้เลยนะคะ
ไดอารี่แอปอะไรคะอ้อครูฟ้ามีแอป My  di
ด้วยเหรอคะมีค่ะมีก็ข้างในเนี่ยก็จะเขียน
เกี่ยวกับสิ่งที่ครูฟ้าเขียนบ้างไม่เขียน
บ้างเพราะขี้เกียจนะคะแต่ว่ามันก็เป็น
สิ่งที่บางเออเพราะว่าบางครั้งมันอาจจะ
ไม่ได้เป็นเรื่องที่เราโกรธใครก็ได้นะแต่
มันเป็นความรู้สึกของเราตอนนั้นที่อาจจะ
รู้สึกเสียใจอะไรก็เขียนใช่ใช่มเราก็ไม่
อยากให้คนอื่นเนี่ยดูเนาออืเออไดอารี่มัน
มันค่อนข้างแบบทุกคนจะหวงอยู่แล้วเขียน
เป็นภาษาอังกฤษด้วนะว่าเดี๋ยวคนไทยอ่าน
ออกออ๋อเขียนเป็นภาษาอังกฤษเนี่ยรู้แล้ว
ทำไมไม่ให้คนอื่นดูทำไมหวงทำไมอื่นอ่าน
ไม่ออกว่าฟ้าแกมม่าผิดนะแมมผิดแมผิดมัน
ให้ครูหญิงอ่านนะคะคนแรก
เลยคะมีอีกมคะครูฟ้าอะไรในโทรศัพท์ที่ครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยหวงไม่อยากให้คนอื่น
ดู LINE ยังไม่หวงเลยอ่ะใครอยากดูไลนครู
ฟ้าก็ดูไปนะคะไม่มีอะไรนะคะเพราะว่าครู
ฟ้าไม่ตอบนะคะใช่ค่ะลายครูฟ้าก็ไม่ห่วงนะ
คะครูฟ้าไม่มีอะไรหรอกค่ะ
สีแดงนะคะก็เลย LINE เนี่ยโอเคไม่เท่า
ไหร่แต่ว่าแล้วพวกเอ่อพวกแพลชอ่าอะไรนะ
มันจะมี LINE ใช่ไหมมพวกข้อความอาจจะเป็น
Messenger หรือว่านักเรียนจะมีอะไรอ่ะ
พวกข้อความ WhatsApp อะไรอย่างเงี้ยอัน
นี้ห่วงมยไม่อืเหมือน LINE ใช่มั้ใช่ LINE
แชทไม่ห่่วงค่ะูฟ้าไม่มีอะไรนะคะตให้ครู
ฟ้าคุยกับแฟนก็ไม่ห่วงนะคะดูสิคะของครู
หญิงห่วงมั้ยครูหญิงใส่พาสเวิร์ดด้วยนะคะ
นี่นะของครูฟ้าเห็นมของูฟ้าเข้าได้เลยของ
ครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะนักเรียนถ้ากด LINE ใช่
มยอืก็เข้า
พาสเวิร์ดหรือว่าถ้าครูฟ้าส่ง LINE มาให้
ครูหญิงอย่างเงี้ยอ่ะสมมุติว่ามีคนส่ง
LINE มามันมันไม่อยู่แล้วอ่ะมันจะไม่
ขึ้นว่าเส่งมาว่าอะไรเพราะว่าครุหญิง
เนี่ยใส่พาเวไเหมือนแบบไม่อยากให้คนอื่น
ดูของผู้หญิงน่าจะหวงแหละอืมันจะขึ้นมา
ว่าครูฟ้าส่งข้อความให้ครูหญิงแต่ไม่
เขียนว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยส่งอะไรเพราะว่าใน
LINE ของครูหญิงเนี่ยมันต้องใส่รหัสนะคะ
4 ตัวใช่ค่ะว่าก็ไม่ห่วงหวงใช่ไม่หวงลาย
แต่ว่าอ่ะหวงเคแบงค์แล้วกันนะ
คะหวงพวมีเงินนิดนิดหน่อยนะะผู้หญิงเห็น
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้ามีเงินอยู่ 50 บาทเองเหรอใน
เบงค์ 50 บาทเองเงินเหรอคะอันนี้คือ
แอปพลิเคชัน Kbank นะคะเป็นแอปที่เอาไว้
เป็นเกี่ยวกับเป็นแอปนใช่มั้ยของคนไทยใช่
ใชเป็นแอปธนาคารอย่างเงี้ยค่ะนักเรียน
เห็นมั้ยก็จะมี K แบงค์ครูหญิงมีเบงค์มี
SCB มีอธนาคารกรุงศรีกรุงศีซึ่งแอป
ธนาคารอันนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าใส่รหัสมั้ยต้อง
ใส่รหัสมั้ยแอปธนาคารทุกแอปต้องใส่รหัส
ค่ะครูหญิงอ่าใส่รหัสแบบนี้เนาะเหมือนของ
ครูหญิงเนี่ยของครูหญิงก็ต้องใส่รหัสนะคะ
ต้องพิมพ์ใชอือือนั่นแหละแล้วก็ูหญิงถาม
ได้มั้ยครูฟ้ารหัสของเคแบงค์ของครูฟ้า
อะไรหรอคะผู้หญิงยังกล้าถามด้วยเหรอ
คะก็ครูฟ้าไม่ค่อยหวงอะไรไงไม่ค่อยมีความ
ลับก็น่าจะบอกครูหญิงได้รรหัสธนาคารก็บอก
ครูหญิงได้นักเรียนบอกมั้ยคะถ้าครูหญิง
ถามไม่บอกค่ะนี้เป็นความลับนะคะไม่ใช่หวง
อย่างเดียวนะอันเนี้ยอันนี้เป็นความลับ
ด้วยอืมีอีกมยอ่ะครูฟ้าที่หวงคือครูหญิง
เนี่ย YouTube ไม่เป็นไรนะคะ Instagram
โอเคเพว่าไม่ค่อยเล่นเท่าไหร่นะคะออของ
ครูหญิงเนี่ยก็ไม่มีแอปพลิเคชันไดอารี่
เนาะแต่มันจะมีแอปโนตโนตนะคะโตอแอปโนต
เนี่ยไม่ไม่ได้จดไดอารี่อะไรไม่ได้หวง
100% ขนาดนั้นแต่ว่าแอปโตมันก็จะมีแบบ
บางคือเราเนี่ยมีโซเชียล Media เยอะมี acc
account อีเมลเยอะบางครั้งเราจำไม่ได้
ว่ารหัสอีเมลหรือว่าพาสเวิร์ดเนี่ยอะไรู
หญิงเนี่ยก็พิมพ์ใส่ไว้ในแอปโตไงใช่คุย
กันเลยคนอื่นูไม่ได้
โอ๊ยูฟาให้คนอื่นดูได้นะแต่ว่าเนี่ยแบบ
เนี้ยพิมพ์ใส่ลงในโน๊ตใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าโน้ต
ครูหญิงส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยคือจะเป็นท็อปปิกไง
ไม่ค่อยได้มีอะไรที่
อ่ะสมมุติอย่างเงี้ยอ่ะรหัสอย่างเงี้ยค่ะ
iPhone ของผู้หญิงเนี่ยเอออะไรอะไรอัน
นี้นักเรียนดูก็คงไม่เป็นไรหรอกเนาะไม่มี
พาสเวิร์ดนะคะเป็นแค่ชื่ออีเมลอืใช่แล้ว
ครูหญิงก็จำไม่ได้ไงครูหญิงก็ต้องพิมพ์
ใส่เอาไว้ในแอปพลิเคชันโนตก็เลยอาจจะหวง
นิดหน่อยว่าออืเดี๋ยวเขาเห็นของเรานะคะ
เคคก็จะบอกว่าอุ๊ยหรือว่าอายพาสเวิร์ดนะ
คะบางทีตั้งพาสเวิร์ดเป็นชื่อรสารไอดอที่
เราชอบอ่ะแล้วิก็จะแบบเธออายุขนาดนี้แล้ว
เธอตั้งพาสเวิร์ดแบบนี้หรอเ้าผู้พ้ายัง
ตั้งมาร์กใจฮยอนได้เลยนะคะเออเห็นมั้ยคะ
ก็เลยห่วงนะงห่วงนิดหน่อยนะคะอืนี่แหละ
หมดแล้วะก็ไม่ค่อยห่วงแล้วอืไม่ห่วงอะไร
แล้วหรอไม่ค่อยห่วงค่ะแอปพิซซ่า grb  Food
L  Man ห่วงมั้
shopee  shopee ก็ไม่นะคะอันนี้คนไทยจะ
มีแอปพลิเคชัน shopee เนาะนักเรียนก็ไม่
ห่วงนะคะสมมุติว่าคู่ฟ้าบอกว่าูหญิงยืม
โทรศัพท์ไปถ่ายรูปหน่อยหิก็ให้เลยเพราะ
ว่าแอปไหนทีู่หญิงหวงครูหญิงต้องใส่ใส่
รหัสไงใช่มั้ยใส่รหัสอย่างอ่าคนอื่นก็ไม่
รู้แต่แอโมันใส่รหัสไม่ได้อ่ะเนาเออใช่
ค่ะเมื่อไหร่แอโฟจะใส่รหัสได้คะแอโฟตจริง
ๆถ้าเป็นครูฟ้าขอโทรศัพท์ครูหญิงไปถ่าย
รูปแล้วอาจจะกดแล้วก็ไปเห็นรูปของครูหญิง
ครูหญิงก็ไม่ค่อยอะไรนะครูฟ้าไม่ไม่แบบ
งี้แอปแอแอปรูปภาพอ่ะค่ะก็ก็โอเคนะไม่ได้
แบบมีรูปภาพที่แบบดูไม่ได้ขนาดนั้นน่ะค่ะ
ไม่มีเลยนะไม่มีเลยไม่หวงเออไม่มีรูปอะไร
แบบที่ไม่โอเคอ่ะค่ะเพราะว่าผู้หญิงสวย
ทุกรูปนะคะนักเรียน
อนั่นแหละค่ะแล้วนักเรียนล่ะมีมยคะอะไร
ที่อยู่ในโทรศัพท์ของนักเรียนที่นักเรียน
เนี่ยหวงมากๆไม่ให้คนอื่นดูหรือว่าไม่
อยากให้คนอื่นเห็นใช่คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้
ได้ค่ะนักเรียนส่วนวดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้ว
ใช่ค่ะเอ้อเนาะเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ใน
วีีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะใช่
สวัสดี
ค่ะ